on s'en souviendra en tout bien aidé ou
encore amoureux messier au bo oui tu
m'aime vraiment dis moi dis c'est quoi
la saint valentin
je suis amoureux mon coeur quand on est
amoureux comme ça quand ça nous prendre
c'est bien la fête des amoureux nous oui
moi je serai bien lamoureux mais
jusqu'au pas de kit avec ses yeux et se
regarde là les amoureux qui bécotent sur
les bancs publics bancs publics bancs
publics en foutant pas ma du regard
oblique débattement
honnête les amoureux qui se bécotent sur
les bancs publics bancs publics situe ce
qu'est la saint valentin c'est la fête
des amoureux
oh non je sais pas ce qui c'est la tête
parce que c'est la fête des amoureux
on en croit décembre
malheureusement français les water ne
peut pas traiter cette affaire ce qu'il
faut avoir toujours des femmes pour un
non tous les bateaux
tous les oiseaux tous les sommets
les ronces toutes les choses qui tout
énervé
cette petite fille demande rue
avez-vous pensé à jeter des fleurs pour
la saint valentin se lancer maintenant
ça oui on est quinze jours c'est le 14
c'est à nous
j attends moi
allez vous fêter la saint-valentin
montrent pas les femmes n'avaient pas
d'idée c'est non non non non non non
grâce à yves à terre à niort si j'arrive
du midi j'essaie de me marier ici mais
ça marche pas oui bah c'est la fête des
amoureux
ça tombe bien pour moi je m'appelle
valentin aussi eh bien oui vous allez
accepter enfin ce bon non c'est pas mon
prénom avec les cheveux gris à savoir un
petit peu quand même
m